did you talk to Joaquin Phoenix at all
when you did the job no not really at
the Joker a little bit at the premiere
but no that's right you're the Joker
yeah he was sort of in it yeah I talked
to DeNiro a bit did you yeah
he didn't really talk to denier I heard
he was just still in character I did
sorry I didn't if he made an interesting
choice that I very much recognized and
and I in the moment I fought to not take
personally like he was doing his thing
and I got that and he was talking to
Todd Phillips that's that's the only
person he was really engages the
director and like I was there for like a
week and change because I'm I'm on the
set the entire last part of the movie
but like when I walk into that room for
that little beat there where you know
I'm saying like in telling DeNiro like
he can't put him on like the green room
right yeah yeah is that to the first
take we did the first take you know and
Joaquin's you know registering me
talking to him but the second take he
chose not even to acknowledge I was very
interesting and it was genius like it
was really like that's what he would do
like once Murray walks into that room
for the first time they Joaquin seeing
this guy Murray like he just that's all
hey and like I'm talking to him he's not
looking at me just focus on yeah yeah
what a beast I'm special dude you guys
didn't see each other and said right you
know I was saying I was in that old
carpet so you had the back of the head
moment I had the you see me in the in a
blurry mirror if you blur your eyes
sometimes it'll two negatives come up
with a positive you can see Bobby Lee on
the spot guys cuz dude when I saw this
much of your face oh yeah oh my god
did you talk to him tadka boy he's a
good buddy no I mean - no no he wouldn't
even but I talked to extras come on
exactly is he wearing a vest okay but
todd todd Cameron's like hey I'm sorry
it's a small role
listen okay we did a whole walking talk
that he cut out like there's the thing
of me and DeNiro walkin ya up to the
dressing room that he cut out and he
said what got skinny I was that [ __ ]
beautiful
I gotta be careful not get too skinny
look fine thanks
I wish I had that problem hey was that a
wig De Niro was wearing it's not a wig
no dear you how dear didn't look like a
weight to me he does do something with
his mouth I don't know what they were
working on but he seemed to do some
teeth before each take he has a person
there I think you know he was nice he
talked to me a little bit he there's
that great moment with the note though
like um oh but before I forget that they
Sophia Phillips cut the walk and talk
and he said look he he he didn't wanna
have anything in the movie that wasn't
that Joaquim wasn't it oh wow I thought
that movie was a master because there's
like an idea that his is real is it not
real so there's nothing in the movie
there's no scene without walking in it
Wow look at that picture
yeah that's a good picture you frame
that cell for now you know damn it on my
phone I wish I should frame it here I
would be my [ __ ] basement blown up oh
yeah maybe I will
yeah that's it that's a that's a
masterpiece that movie didn't you think
her what do you think of the movie I
thought that like you know there was a
couple of things I would have done
differently to it would have been better
I think if we sympathized with the his
character more before he goes bad
like I think there was something odd
about like he like cool in who is the
director of my girlfriend she said like
if they just had one scene at the
beginning of the movie of him actually
entertaining children him being north
yeah that makes sense
do you know - well I'm happy to me like
it was it was almost over over-the-top
yeah I left her just going like wow
Jesus man yeah like he's already bro
dark yeah or it would have been nice to
see the heartbreak that caused him to be
the mom yeah that's a little bit yeah
but um but oh the the moment was great
because he liked De Niro's a real pro
you know we're talking isn't no mean I'm
sure he wouldn't know me now to be
honest with you I don't you mean and you
know it's like how many guys like have
done that with it yes you know what I
mean that you know it's his job but but
here's the thing like so the first take
when we're doing the walking talk I'm me
you know I always come always I'm
waiting all day to do the thing and so
my grandmother and I'm doing the thing
and Todd goes cut and then I stop and
see the DeNiro walk over he sits down
for a second then he gets up he walks
over the Todd and then walks back with
chair and then Todd walks over to be and
Todd goes like you're coming in a little
hot like you know do my Maris a right
he's a Lynott's he says you remember
he's your boss you know my car
good know that [ __ ] but DeNiro hands
oh like you're probably not gonna tell
me yeah he said the drugs like I'm his
boss right so he's you know I usually do
yelling before you don't I mean yeah
that's interesting
yeah well that's that's how you work
together he's um I always feel like when
you work with yeah when you work with De
Niro like the way you did I feel like
for him it would be like the way a
dentist sees that many patients they're
not gonna remember you don't have it
like there wasn't enough between us for
us to really dig in you know like but
but like all I think a market at your
level do so does your agent call you a
hey we we want you to audition do we
just want you read for this odd love
stand-up comic so he knows yeah he
offered me it wasn't this part he
offered me actually the other part where
whatever when when he know he when the
the guy when the guy fires him all the
boss of the cloud yeah yeah well he
Bruins a sign he's I can't like I let
you go man yeah yeah yeah that was the
one thing I read for oh your is better
yeah but then he said I got this for you
he said this is I think this is better
yeah I agree but but the thing is is
like you know I couldn't really dig in
with DeNiro
so what my approach to it was like you
know just do your thing man don't like
the good thing about the podcast is like
I've met so many guys that are huge or
you know and they're they're they're
really just people and they become
people very quickly for me it doesn't
faze you anymore yeah I've got something
inside me because I you know like so
you're just a guy and in that it's
really it's kind of true of course
correct you know so once you got that in
your head you can just do your what a
very peculiar skill on a particular
skill but they're all struggling but
that's the weird thing you watch this
thing man I watched him me like he what
he couldn't get his wines completely and
like the other one you know
and it was all very fragmented but they
know where the cameras they know how
it's gonna cut and like you know give it
like watching what was going on in the
studio and then watching the final cut
I'm like holy [ __ ] yeah that's the magic
of these dudes right they know exactly
they know what's going like yeah like
who was at Jeff Daniel said to me says
you got to learn how to what how to use
your face Jeremy Piven was that way he
taught me that on Entourage he said he
goes look the way they're gonna edit
this he knew exactly how to edit you
know exactly and he he was directing me
quietly he was like that when you start
this to start this way otherwise they
won't use the tape everything the good
gonna do it so long yeah they just it's
all I have I have the time I don't know
what [ __ ] cameras on yeah I'm like
I'm just in my clothes man it's still me
I do it every day I'm like it's my
close-up hour
but I do have this trick that I do now
like I make a joke about it with the
Lynne and I did it in it's too bad you
can't isolate the clip where I do this
thing where I get this I'm walking away
so you get the land yeah okay okay get
your face timing closure scene funding
the scene that's Marin just button the
scene right there yeah there it is it's
a book in the [ __ ] book end of it
yeah were you uh but I'm sure you
learned all ton doing shooting Marin
there was it three know that I knew that
was it was four seasons that I knew that
was that was my school like I got the
gig I knew that I was probably kind of
sucked the first season if I get the
hang of it and then as a one on I get
more comfortable with not one and two
are the best seasons
I do too yeah probably I thought I loved
the last season because it was weird I
love really weird I love to relapse I
like the rehab yeah and but like I knew
or was there a learning curve to it but
I'm getting better now I'm like sort of
like trying to figure out like I'm
noticing more about acting where you're
coming from your intentions and [ __ ] you
know what I mean
making those adjustments you're making
decisions like I still feel like there's
an engine for me to get better yeah and
I think I'm getting I was
think about what I'm what am i doing in
the scene what is what do I want from
that careful I'm real bad with sort of
like especially when you're shooting a
show and you're shooting a to order at a
time sequence we're like what was
happening right before this yeah that's
the trickiest thing for me to get yeah I
try to just break it down to that I go
what do I want and what do I want from
this character what am I trying good
some of that to Nate right you're kind
to know it yeah but you got to put it in
the place but more like some you know
the world turns like if someone just
goes you're not as like you'reyou're
less hungry or whatever like you to play
that kind of stuff problem with it
that's a bad director sometimes
directors don't know how to speak to you
so what they'll do is they'll say
something like this gotta be happier
well I don't know even by happier I
don't know so so what do you want me to
do to that person now if you said to me
scare that person charm that person
flirt right like those are good right
now now I have you're giving me
something tonight and he can throw a
little switching yeah I'm gonna or have
you said um you know try to make them
laugh with that you know do something
different right now now I'm now you're
now you're gonna make me look happy yeah
when you say how would you in the world
would you ever play sexy and I'm gonna
play sexy huh even when they say you
know try to seduce her I give you better
off like you want her yes yeah that's
different because if you were to say to
me here's a good now you want her but
she she doesn't yeah if you said to me
seduce her I was I don't have more time
well that's what I described a direct
sale clearly look at her look at her
she's so beautiful it should make you it
should actually make you look at her
like you smell something bad because
she's so good-looking that you're just
like this so you're my god you're going
am I getting to it oh yeah like what is
your name yeah yeah this stinks I can't
right yeah now now you go this guy
alright this guy really likes her you
know it so that they're a good director
can really help you navigate a role by
telling you what to do yeah that's right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tone
oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]